[Music]
what's up Wolfgang today we're gonna be
talking about what happened to the
Infinity Gauntlet at the end of infinity
war today's video will obviously contain
some spoilers so if you have not seen
Avengers infinity war yet you should not
watch this video also be sure to enter
our giveaway for a full speaker system
all you have to do is be subscribed to
this channel subscribe to the stupendous
wave leave a like and drop a comment
below with your favorite superhero
Marvel DC or otherwise
okay last spoiler warning cuz here we go
so at the end of Avengers infinity war
Thanos gets all the stones for the
Infinity Gauntlet snaps fingers and
wipes out half of the universe but did
you notice how after he used it the
Infinity Gauntlet was sort of beat-up
and decaying at the end to answer that
we have to answer the question of why
the Infinity Gauntlet was created in the
first place as we learn in the movie
Thanos forces King III who is king of
the dwarves of neduvaali R to make him
the Infinity Gauntlet in the scene on
neduvaali earth or asking Eitri what he
did and what she replies Thanos came and
asked them to make something capable of
holding all of the Infinity stones at
once so if you remember in the first
guardians of the galaxy we learned that
nobody is able to hold an infinity stone
with their bare hands at least not for
an extended period of time without dying
ronan was able to hold it for a brief
period of time before he shoved it into
his hammer and peter quill was able to
hold it for a little bit but that's
because he's part celestial and if you
remember in the beginning of Infinity
Ward when Evan e-ma speaking to fantasy
he says that nobody has ever been able
to wield more than one Infinity stone at
the same time until Thanos you may have
also noticed that Thanos was able to
hold the Infinity stones like they were
nothing like they were just ordinary
little pebbles this is because he's one
of the most powerful beings in the
universe and he's also what's known as a
titanium eternal basically he's really
strong that's why I can hold him
but even danos himself can't hold all of
the Infinity stones at the same time
which is why he asked a tree to wield
him the Infinity Gauntlet the stones are
just too powerful to be used all at once
without some sort of device used to
harness them and concentrate their power
if you noticed and if you pay close
attention
the movie everytime famous uses the
Infinity Gauntlet and infinity stone
lights up usually just one but sometimes
two that's because he's using the
Infinity stones one out of time for each
of their specific powers that it gives
to him but at the end when he snaps his
fingers and gets rid of half of the
universe he's using all of the Infinity
stones to do it so when he comes back
from what I believed to be Sol world
from speaking with baby Gamora he looks
at the Infinity Gauntlet and it is just
in decay even Thanos is surprised that
the gauntlet is in decay this goes to
show you the power of all the Infinity
stones even the Infinity Gauntlet it was
made by King III who is the master
forger and it was made from a dying star
neduvaali R can't take the power of all
the Infinity stones together the powers
just too much and that's why it's all
messed up and destroyed at the end after
he snaps his fingers so the real
question is now does the Infinity
Gauntlet still work if it does then you
can count on Avengers for being about
somehow getting the Infinity Gauntlet to
be able to reverse everything that's
happened if it doesn't then they're
going to have to find another way
perhaps using the time stone just by
itself or perhaps using some pimp
technology or start technology to go
back in time maybe when Avengers
infinity war is out of theaters in a
couple of months they'll start giving us
trailers for Avengers 4 and we'll learn
more information but until then we'll
just have to wait and see well that's it
for today's video I hope you all enjoyed
it let me know what you guys thought of
Avengers infinity war in the comments
below and don't forget to join the wolf
game by subscribing to my channel and
don't forget about our giveaway all you
have to do to win a full speaker system
is subscribe to my channel subscribe to
the stupendous wave give this video a
like and drop a comment below with your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching
woof woof going through the big one
a devil's anus hey wait who's anus for
the record I didn't know it was called
that when I picked it that looks like a
collapsing neutron star inside of an
einstein-rosen bridge we need another
ship that will tear mine to pieces she's
right